ladies and gentlemen welcome to tim
dillon show we do apologize for there
being no video we also apologize for our
lateness i don't think we've really
ever been late with an episode before
we may have been but don't bring it up
and the reason that we were late is
because we are traveling
um we are moving the studio across the
country that is also the reason for no
video we were just at whataburger
which is a very average and uh i know
people get angry when i say that but
i mean i don't understand the hoopla
have people never been out of their
homes
i mean what what is the pride with that
it's it's fine
i mean the barbecue bacon burger is good
but the plain water bur i mean what are
we doing
it's the same thing with in and out you
know devin and ida get really excited
about in and out
you know i mean people get excited about
fast food
you know and they're not embarrassed
either they're
they shamelessly now taco bell is
different
taco bell is an iconic cultural
experience but
these other places are not uh they're
simply not and i don't know
what to tell you but we did just want to
apologize to that you know
you know you're consuming something
that's completely free so you deserve it
exactly when we
uh give it to you to be quite honest
most of you some of you are paying for
the patreon but we're
we're always on time with that ben
showed me a video it's still kind of
it's still sits with me
and can we play the audio uh yeah do you
know what i'm talking about yeah i'll
put the audio in right here are we
allowed to put the audio in
um i wonder if it could get flagged
especially this early in the episode
too it's really
heinous i mean not a lot of stuff
rattles me and this rattled me it's a
murder double murder suicide
in philadelphia over
the shoveling of snow i don't even
it i guess there was a couple and they
were using a snowblower or they were
using
shovels shovels yeah and they were
shoveling snow
onto another dude's driveway onto his
lawn
onto his lawn yeah and
he there they were at at war
yeah this has been removed from twitter
now if you're trying to find it by the
way
and it's a video of the guy and they're
calling him it's a couple and they're
like
what are you gonna do [ __ ] and it's
like a scene from fargo
i don't know because it's snowing and
it's just blanketed
with snow and then the guy comes
out of his house the guy that the the
couple is
shoveling the snow on his lawn they're
calling him [ __ ] what are you going to
do
[ __ ] we're going to make your life a
living hell we're going to make your
life a living hell
yeah i mean what a you know
when you say something like that
it gets to people when you choose those
words we're gonna make your life a
living hell
and he leaves his house shoots them
both in the street they're crawling
around in the street
then he goes back into his house what
does he get an ak-47 ar-15
ar-15 he comes back out
and he he looks at the woman and this is
where i
even as i talk about it it's creepy
you're watching the end of somebody's
life
he looks at her and he goes you should
have kept your mouth shut
and then he shoots her in the head and
then he goes and shoots the husband
it was so viscerally disturbing and i'm
usually not
disturbed i usually don't watch
executions all the time but i've seen
things
and i'm still this
video for whatever reason lodged
in my head and
it's because
i'm horrified watching it you get a bad
feeling from the moment the video begins
playing
you know something very bad is gonna
happen
it's eerie usually you don't feel that
but from the minute it starts playing
you go this
isn't something fun this doesn't end
in a fun this isn't a snowball fight
there's something about i don't know
what it is but there's an
energy there you go you know this is
going to go off the rails
you don't know how bad it's going to be
and then when he comes out and he shoots
them both and goes back in
gets an ar then comes back
out and shoots her and he hears the
thing
and then he kills himself right goes
back inside the cops come he blows his
head off
yeah and
here's the thing right you watch this
guy
shoot a woman point blank in the face
in the middle of a street with an ar-15
and right before he shoots her he says
he goes you should have kept your mouth
shut and you're watching
it and it's so horrifying
but
now now i have to be delicate here
but three little letters what a word
but
she should have kept her mouth shut
and the last things she's gonna hear
on this earth is the greatest lesson
she'll ever learn and it's sad
that it had to be that way
i'm not condoning his actions but
there's
something about shooting someone point
blank in the face
and delivering a message that they need
to hear
it's tough to watch
you could probably find it on the dark
web or something it's floating around
you don't even have to go to the dark
web it's tough to watch i don't even
even know where ben
finds these things i don't know what he
even does i don't know what he does with
his time when he's not with me
i don't know what he does he just sits
in his garage and
watching people murder each other what
what is wrong with him
but i was i felt bad that it ended the
way it did where everybody died
but i did i did feel
that that woman needed to hear and her
husband
it's not about gender that that woman
needed to hear
those words and it's sad that after that
he shot a point blank in the face
with the ar
but it's it's hard because you watch it
and you just you you watch the video and
you go
you know well number one
how's the quarantine working out for
everyone
uh because i this probably this might
have happened before the pandemic
or before this you know whatever it is a
pandemic but i mean before this
shut down i don't know this last year
has has sent people
to the edge to the brink and when you
watch this you go yeah this
seems to be something that
is the result of people being pushed to
their
breaking point and he broke and he shot
this woman and her husband
watching them crawl around on the snow
is so rattling
it's disturbing watching them crawl
around
for a good 60 seconds crawl around on
the stove
watching that is really really disturbed
but but
they were being very antagonistic
they were this is the thing
it's you it it
they're saying that the guy gonna make
your life living hell
call him [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do and he just had
it
i'm not saying i enjoyed watching it it
disturbed me
i've covered that but what i'm saying
is that it's very difficult
to not understand
a fraction of the man's anger
he did not handle it in a productive way
you know i was taken back by though like
i i've watched videos that are similar
to that before
never that i found like this freak
but people show me [ __ ] and go look at
this i go ugh
you know and and this really took a
mental residence in my mind
because it was just this snowy bleak day
in philly
and people it was just hatred on display
like a scene out of fargo like the end
of fargo
it was rough to watch
it made me deeply
sad truly about the future of humanity
and about the effects that this period
has had on
everybody but
i did like seeing that woman get shot in
the face
because because
sometimes you do want to shoot somebody
in the face point blank
and when he looks at it he goes you
should have kept your mouth
shut and she knows what's coming
and she knows she pushed the wrong
person and she's laying in the snow
about to get shot in the head this this
episode will get lighter
but as she's about to get shot in the
head she's laying in the street
probably what went through her mind is i
should have kept my mouth shut
maybe i should have kept my mouth shut
and it's hey
sad all around not advocating it
wouldn't do it wouldn't advise it
tough to watch not good don't go look
for the video it will be disturbing
unless you're into that in which case
it's great
if you're into it don't get into it
don't be that guy
unless this is how you come and try not
to be that guy either
um what were your feelings on the video
because you're the one who [ __ ]
brought it into my life
i'm sorry i'm so slow no i mean i
i think i've i think i've been quite
clear here it was a it was a mixed bag
it's like this weird like norman
rockwell scene where it's just a couple
shoveling their snow and then all of a
sudden
like within 30 seconds they're both
laying in a pool of their own blood
it's just i mean it's horrific it's a
horrific thing all caught on the
the by the way the videos from one of
those doorbells
like a ring a ring cam yeah and then you
know halfway through it too their
autistic
son runs out the couple to check on them
and then when he sees him coming back in
with the ar-15 he runs off and then
that's when he does the execution shots
so there's like a whole scene developing
there of them trying to help
the mom and him trying to help his mom
and dad and then the guy just comes back
out
and does the deed well
i'll tell you one thing that kid's not
gonna step out of line
you know you want to talk about a polite
kid
you want to talk about a polite kid
i watch my mother get shot in a grill
for running her fat mouth and i've
learned
to just let it happen let life happen
and i feel bad for him and i feel bad
for everyone involved here
but is there any better way to ensure
that somebody's gonna be
you know a little passive
i mean by the way those parents were no
great shakes
for that kid i'm not saying they should
have been executed in front of them
but they were not that was not going to
be
a great life with them you know
maybe there's family maybe the grand the
grandparents took him in i read the
article
better situation better situation
do you think in that woman's high school
yearbook
she was voted most likely to get shot in
the face
outside of her house while shoveling
snow
because that should be a new category in
philly high school yearbooks it should
be
most likely to get shot point-blank
range by an ar-15
by an angry neighbor who you are
harassing
it would be so much easier to feel bad
for them if they weren't like plus your
part what are you gonna do
buddy that was your whole thing they
were like what are you gonna do you do
something about it
you know they would just like do
something about it do something about it
do something about it and then finally
the guy stopped
what's interesting is he shot them both
he comes out with what a handgun yeah
with a nine millimeter
and he shoots them and goes that's not
enough and you watch the guy crawl into
the garage
again very disturbing and then he goes
back in the house and you think the
video's ending because she's like call
the cops
and you think oh the video's ending and
and i got to be honest
as a video as a piece of media
as media it's disappointing
because it doesn't feel like there's
closure
i'm being very honest the guy crawls
into the garage and then the woman is
like call the cop
and she's still being annoying she's
shot
and in the street and still pushing
everybody's buttons
and you're like you know this is
needs a resolution and then he comes out
with the ar
and a part of you goes oh no
but then a part of you perks up because
you go
just a second ago i said there was not
going to be a resolution here
now i think there might be oh and there
is and and there's something about
the the final words there really is
and again if you know these people i
mean
you know sorry
there's something about the final words
uh you
should have kept me out she goes you
shoulda kept
your mouth shut
he says that to her and then he just
blows her head away
and
then he shoots the guy then he walks
into the garage and gets him
we don't hear if he said anything to him
i don't think he did
because it's like it's hard to follow up
where you go you should have kept your
mouth shut boom
and then you're gonna have a real good
line
and now if you don't have joel and ethan
cohen doing it like fargo
you're not gonna have a good line for
the husband
i mean he could have said something like
when he walked into the garage the
husband could have said something like
you know
um i don't even know i'm on the spot now
but if he like looked at him and he was
like
hey you know uh
i don't know like time for you to join
your wife or something
you know something i don't know
i'm on the spot here it's hard yeah like
a rotten hell really when it worked it
doesn't no
not after not after the very succinct
there's no fat in that sense you should
have kept your mouth shut
there's not one extra syllable he was it
was succinct
it was clear the message was delivered
with precision
as as are well the shots were as well
but
to then to the husband you got you he
probably walked in there and from split
second was like
do i have something good for him too
and then he was like i don't and i i
just got to shoot him so he shot him
it'd be great if he just had something
good
you know but you know those guys at
philly he'd get hockey
he'd be like say hello to my little
friend like something hacky where you
like oh this is disappointing
that's the thing about long island any
of my friends
who will certainly do this i i know
people who will definitely shoot people
in the face probably over shoveling snow
but the last thing they say to them will
be such a hacky
dumb derivative line
from like ace ventura when nature calls
like they will say something that has
nothing
to do you know they'll just they'll do a
jim carrey line from the mask
you know they'll be like smoking
somebody stop yeah somebody stop me like
it'll have not
it will be completely cartoonish and
embarrassing
uh and then they won't my friends won't
kill themselves because they don't have
that level of intelligence
so then the cops they'll have to play
out in court what they said
and they'll be like some guy that was
like going like some neighbor that was
like
yeah uh i think he yelled say hello to
my little friend
and they're like the line from scarface
yeah he yelled that
and then he shot her in the head
you know like yeah yeah he said nobody
puts
baby in a corner and then shot her in
the mouth
we were confused we didn't know how the
original argument started
no nobody i know from long island would
have like to just say you should have
kept your mouth shut
it's a real movie
quality line to deliver
and i'm judging i am judging this only
as
media as content i am not
saying murder is good i am saying
as content as content because i'm a
consumer of content
as we all are and when ben showed it to
me i said well this is content
it's content it's a double murder
suicide he goes
he said to me he goes it's a double he
be warned because it's a double murder
suicide in philadelphia
over uh uh snow shoveling but then i i
settle in
and then i go okay but i'm still
expecting it to be good right i still
want it to be good
and it was good because it's you think
it ends and it does it he goes back in
the house
and then he comes out and he has a great
line so as content and what is it three
minutes
uh two minutes and 20 seconds it's
perfect perfect for twitter yeah yeah
perfect for twitter yeah two minutes and
20 seconds perfect for twitter
whoa and of course for igtv you put it
on igtv
with a nice cover photo of the guy
standing over the woman with the ar-15
it's content folks don't get sensitive
i'm looking at it as a piece of content
as you should and that guy then goes in
and how does he kill himself what did he
do
uh i think the ar-15 just in the mouth
yeah
wow cause he didn't want to go through
the trial he didn't want to go through
the whole thing
yeah it's getting bad out there
it's been bad out there have you been
making excuses for your weight loss or
lack thereof
with each passing day you were growing
farther apart from the body you once had
open up your phone look at a picture of
you from 15 years ago
and then gaze at the face in your
bathroom mirror
chance well this is dark chances are it
doesn't look good and feels even worse
you can't bring back your innocence but
you can lose the fat
one way one of the best ways to make a
change
is with massives 10-day
fasting smashing greens
integrity and accountability challenge
that rolls off the tongue doesn't it
go to massivesupplements.com and check
this out they've come up with a unique
challenge where the average weight loss
is 15 pounds in 10 days
though it doesn't end there if you
complete both the integrity and
accountability challenges
they'll even pay you 500 cash
what is the integrity and accountability
challenge apologize for hitting your
wife
all you have to do is lose weight don't
be a [ __ ] mindset is everything
those are actual quotes from the program
don't be a [ __ ]
these are good what are these doctors
huh this
is how it works during the 10 days you
want to fast
except for the massive supplements
vitamins and shakes made with massive
signature meal replacement
the smashing greens the smashing greens
i love how they were designing this
you're like what if we we made them it
was like the hulk
we call it smash and people are too
stupid to realize they should have
greens
but if we call them smash ingredients it
makes it's it's our two favorite things
fitness and violence
during the 10 days you get the greens
the greens are extremely nutrient-dense
blend of organic superfoods with no
filters
so if you want to rough someone up in a
stairwell
you've got the [ __ ] goods to do it
the ingredients were all specifically
chosen to maximize micronutrients
curb hunger maximize energy clear skin
burn fat and turn you into the biggest
piece of [ __ ] imaginable
do you want to be a big piece of [ __ ]
massive will make you
not only in great shape but person that
is
loathed by everyone your friends your
family and your significant other but
don't worry
you could just crack her across the face
massive has every top-notch supplement
you could ever need
they have pre-workouts gain supplements
yeah this is going to turn you into
somebody that just writes gains on
instagram while you lift weights
multivitamins creatine a wide array of
protein shakes
and even incredible coffee chris de
stefano is a daily drinker of massive
coffee it's podcast attendant
and as said that it got him so jacked up
it played a part in the dissolution of
history hyenas
it's like hey buddy hey buddy how about
less podcasting and more focus on your
business
you know what i mean if i read an ad for
berkshire hathaway
warren buffett's like talking about calm
down how about you
log off for five minutes
massive also sent me a box of all the
products i was talking about
i of course tried everything and
especially love the shirt i received
received which said defund the media
what kind of insane
whose company is this is this the guy
with the horns of the capitals company
it sounds like his company massive holes
i did try to shake it was good
so what are you waiting for lose the
weight
lose the weight and go fight your mother
[Music]
lose the weight go find your father and
beat the [ __ ] out of him in a
parking lot visit massivesupplements.com
that's m-a-s-f
supplements.com and use the promo code
tim d for 10 percent
all full orders across the site don't be
a [ __ ] truly if you want to lose weight
really quick
which is good early on it motivates you
to keep going with it
um give this psychopath money go to
t use tim d for 10 all orders across the
site
don't be a [ __ ] is there something
interfering with your happiness
or preventing you from achieving your
goals better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it is not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log in your
account anytime
send a message to your counselor you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses
you can schedule weekly video and phone
sessions you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they can
make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials that are
posted daily
okay they're amazing betterhelp.com timd
betterhelp.com timd timd
that's betterhelp join over the 1
million people taking charge of their
mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50
states special offer for the tim dillon
show listeners
you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.comd
that's 10 off your first month with
betterhelp.com
tim d we all know coronavirus
covet 19 is a random devastating
thing we get it probably lab made
more and more credible people are saying
that now that will probably be
uh something that becomes an accepted
belief
sooner rather than later maybe not a bio
weapon but certainly
a manipulated virus for maybe research
purposes
or a bioweapon we don't know
in some stage of development but a lot
of people are saying that now
and we get it it's incredibly
unpredictable and strange
um but it's a sophie's choice that we we
cannot keep everything closed down we
know that it's not possible
somebody has to work and then the rage
at like chappelle
and rogan and anyone that's gotten on a
stage and
done stand-up comedy and the rage at
restaurants opening
outside i understand people could
criticize and go hey i do not agree with
this i
i don't think it's but the rage people
that don't understand
that there are as thomas always there's
no solutions here
only trade-offs only
you know the rage that people have
at small businesses for opening
uh at reduced capacity i can't wrap my
head
around it i think it's that there's a
lot listen
when you read these twitter accounts of
the people that are truly
angry at at people for opening
restaurants or doing comedy shows
does anyone believe that those people
care about people does anyone think that
that's coming from an
altruistic place that they're concerned
about people's health
or do these people just hate life
and they love the idea that they're not
gonna have to leave their home
and shake somebody's hand and look them
in the eye
and participate in any social situation
and they like that they like it because
on the internet they have
maybe something going on maybe maybe
they have
8 000 twitter followers
but in real life many of these people
don't exist truly they don't exist
they're like vapers they're barely there
they are strange
gaunt odd
anti-social people who hate
real life they have found
solace uh on the internet
which is where they would like life to
stay forever
and i think a lot of that's where a lot
of the rage
comes from like the anger at a
restaurant
and cases are dropping now cases are
falling
and you know if you can't open up when
cases are falling
and you you can't open up people against
you opening up when cases are
rising when would you open up
well when there are no cases when no one
is sick
what makes no sense
i just read an article in the financial
times they're like some guy this is what
amazes me that people get paid
to write articles like this a guy goes
like this the financial times he goes
yeah i don't think uh containment with
china is gonna work
you think because yeah because i'm
looking at the stats here and uh
i just don't think we're gonna be able
to contain china
i don't think we're gonna be able to put
him in a box
oh good i'm glad someone wrote you a
check
for that take how studious
and then he went through all the reasons
martin wolf yeah
he went through all the reasons he's
like yeah china's economy
more powerful than the soviet unions
this that and the other
and it's like yeah yeah it's probably a
bad course of action
to uh and i mean
he's like yeah we're gonna have to learn
to cooperate with them oh yeah
yeah i think so i i would
i would say that that's probably gonna
yeah i don't think we're gonna be able
to
smack them around we're not going to be
able to run out of our house with an
ar-15 and blow their head away
it's going to be a bit difficult we're
going to have to work together
to get the snow off the street that's
what we're going to have to do
what do you think by the way about your
boy elon musk because i know you love
tesla so much
saying they're going to be fully
self-driving in like what
two weeks he's he's been saying that for
like three years
yeah a lot of people think he's full of
[ __ ] yeah a lot of people think he's
just foolish but when he says stuff like
that the stock
just goes up a great yeah that's great
good
well i hope when you're in your car and
you're incinerated
the stock price makes you feel
comfortable as you and your wife
are burning to death in your tesla
because this guy told you it was going
to drive you home
maybe it will one day i don't really
know you know
everybody's so goddamn sensitive now so
if elon musk hears this uh we're kidding
elon
and we don't know if we're kidding yet
we'll let you know
hopefully ben still gets to work every
day everyone is so goddamn sad
you can't say anything about anybody
anymore
without a problem you know like i made
the joke about
eric weinstein alex friedman i was like
on the patreon i go
what have these guys done they're
clearly smart guys
the joke is about the fact that like
yes they're both you know lex is uh
in robotics and everything's brilliant
guy and eric weinstein's very smart and
everything
but like you know the trans discussion
has sucked all of the oxygen out of the
room so i'm sure these people
have brilliant takes on other issues but
is it fair to say that the trans issue
has been on the forefront and i'm for
one
i'm a little bored of the truck i don't
care anymore
if you cut your tits off or sew a dick
on
i don't care what you call yourself it
doesn't bother me
if you want to become an uh a woman so
you can
beat them up in a ring i'm almost
for that as long as you look at them
before you do it and go you should have
kept your mouth
shut but what i'm saying is
i'm not saying i'm kid they're clearly
very intelligent people
but like why is everyone now a guru
why do people jump out of their lane
and they become a guru for every issue
in life no one has any type of
specialization
anymore if peop i mean
everybody is just like like
firing wildly going yeah
i i'm i'm a scientist or i'm this or i'm
that
and also i know everything
about everything i should be your go-to
for every question you have about any
issue that could ever come up now or in
the future
that's where i get confused it's not
that they're not smart
it's not that they're not they don't
have valuable things to say i just get
confused
as to how everybody immediately becomes
a guru
overnight people just become they just
decide i uh
you got problems i'll tell you what it
is what are we doing today race
gender sexuality vaccines
what do we got put it on the whiteboard
i got the answer
i got the answer bring it on weather
war religion what's
on the grill today sizzle it up
salt pepper it it's ready to go
i don't have to let anything marinate
i'm ready to go
it's just fascinating that's all that's
all i'm ever saying
i love everyone who support them
i'm just curious as to how everybody
uh is an expert in every issue that
could
ever arise from any discipline
ever that's interesting to me
that's all and maybe that's the case
maybe it's the case that there are seven
intelligent people
and the rest of the world are hacks and
chills
i don't know that's youtube you go on
youtube
basically the premise of of youtube is
i get it and everyone else that's ever
lived or studied this issue
is either a bad faith actor
hack shill has been bought off
is a liar is being blackmailed and
i have figured it out and nobody else
has
that's all it's curious to me
it's curious and then if you make jokes
people get angry at you the people by
the way
who defend jokes
defend comedy and they always go out and
go comedy's being
neutered by the pc police and then you
make jokes about them and they go
ah
actually uh we don't like that
you go well wait a minute i don't
understand
i thought comedians were vital
so i thought this was a vital activity
what and they go well yeah yeah but i
don't know
i don't know people get angry at you
the same the people get angry at you for
kidding around and you go yeah it's a
joke i'm the comedian you shouldn't take
me seriously
no one should it's a comedy podcast
maybe i say some interesting things
maybe i'm right about some of what i say
but uh it's a goof
i look at [ __ ] that may or may not be
[ __ ] and i call it out
it may not be [ __ ] and it may be
[ __ ]
but that's where a lot of my comedy
comes from
uh okay and then the people that are
like all these people that are like
you know the comedians are being you
know there's a
the backlash now to the backlash as a
smarter friend of mine has said
is becoming as sanctimonious as the woke
people
the other side of the wok they're they
are now
as boring as the woke you know
used to watch the woke people and go
jesus christ
shut up and now the other side you're
like
jesus christ you should also shut up
should we just get academics completely
out of public life should we just exile
academic i don't know
but it's just this sanctimonious
all the time the left is waging a war
on your private choices they want
you to be completely and then if you
you make a few and they're like and they
always love comedy of all these people
because the left is insane and the woke
people do go after comedy
and they do take people's jobs and i
understand that
so the people that recognize that i
applaud and then you go yeah but you're
also a little goofy and then they go who
hello
wait a minute wait a minute
you're giving ammunition to the other
side somebody said that to me they go
when you make fun of those people whom
you agree with i go yeah i agree with a
lot of them
but they go yeah but if you make fun of
me give ammunition to the other side and
go
but that's the exact argument that
leftists or not leftists per se but
you know liberal or whatever you want to
call them woke
social justice warriors that's the same
argument that they used they said
you can't make a joke about race because
you're a racist and you're giving
ammunition to racist
so if i make a joke about barry why or
whoever the [ __ ] i'm talking about eric
weinstein whatever
i'm giving ammunition to
the lunatics who think that gender is
you know created
that bill maher created gender or
whatever whatever these [ __ ] lunatics
in san francisco believe
i'm giving ammunition to them because
i've made a joke about someone that
disagrees with them
it's the same sjw playbook it's the same
exact thing
it's actually the same exact thing it's
we like comedy when it fits in the
the box of what we would like it to and
uh
it doesn't really matter it's just
comedy except if it's directed at us
it's a powerful force that must be
vanquished
vanquished unless it is exactly what we
want it to be
make fun of us in the way that you want
us to be made fun of please
thank you thank you they love roasts
all these uh you know the tech people
the people on clubhouse or any of these
guys i i talked to
they're all like yeah comedy's about
roasting
no it's not roasting for the most part
is pretty stupid there are some people
that are brilliant at it
uh geraldo and jeff frost whatever you
go back throughout history
it's important commit it's like an
important comedic skill
you should every good comic should have
a little bit of it but it's boring
it's it's you know it's it's very
formulaic there's nothing there
you're fat you're gay you're bald you're
black you're the there's nothing there
dummies but some of the most successful
people in the world they love
roasting because god forbid a comedian
say anything
that makes them think and they have some
existential moment
so they just like can you call them a
[ __ ] please cause i don't know
so when you meet a lot of these people
that are that are successful
they think the comedian's job's like
roast them
yo thrash them you go
trash that guy who can't like
is there anything more boring than that
by the way is there anything more boring
than watching people just trade insults
back and forth what
level i mean i just don't understand but
that's what a lot of
very smart very successful people love
they love watching people insult each
other
that is their idea of comedy that's what
they think it is
it's just insult pick look at a brown
guy
say he's a terrorist that's comedy
you know it's really crazy but
i don't want to get in the weeds over
this
and then everybody goes then everybody's
response is like why don't i just come
on the show and we'll hash it out and
it's like no i don't
i don't want to do this for five hours
of a lecture
i don't want to do it i respect you i
think you're smart but at the end of the
day it's like
i'm so deeply suspicious of people who
level accusations
at people and then they themselves
exhibit that behavior it's like the q
anon people who are going away for child
porn
right that wasn't shocking because they
spent 18 hours a day thinking about
child porn so it's also not shocking to
me that if you call people snowflakes
for years and years and years
and then somebody says something about
you and then you actually become the
snowflake
because it's like oh you are intimately
acquainted with the idea
of what a snowflake is because you are
exhibiting those characteristics
yourself
you know it's one of the other folks
either comedy doesn't matter and it's
fun
and you can like it or not and take from
it what you want
leave the rest or it's an important
social force
that everyone needs to govern pick one
please pick one can't be everything
can't be everything it can't be like hey
it's just a joke and then
when it's about something you don't like
you go whoa wait a minute
i saw that after the white house
correspondents dinner with michelle
wolfe
when she did that and then everybody
came in all the same people that were
like dudes left us your snowflakes and
michelle
made a few jokes about trump and these
people lost their goddamn mind
i'm just learning i'm just learning
that's all i'm doing here get mad at me
i'm insignificant
i don't matter yeah i have an audience
because we have fun and we say funny
stuff
and some of it makes a lot of sense
that's not my fault
that's not my fault you know when i make
fun of gary vee i don't hate gary vee
he's probably a really good guy i'm sure
he's helped people
but the advice he gives is very vague
and general
it's uh ridiculous
the words he uses and the uh the way he
arranges them
is ridiculous so for somebody to not
call that out is uh that i wouldn't be
doing my job
if i pulled up garyvee quotes and read
them aloud
and said now that i've told you these
things go start a business
you would look at me like i was on i was
smoking
rock cocaine smoking crack you'd go wait
what
and i'm like yeah you know kindness is
speed and empathy is
uh marketing is queen and content is
king and
you know gratitude is whatever go go do
it now
your gratitude is uh gratitude is speed
what whatever he's saying but i'm sure
he's a smart guy and i'm sure
he said things that have value to
certain people
but it's funny imagining people trying
to
fashion a sense of what the hell is
going on in their life and in their
business
from the quotes that dribble out of his
mouth it's you know
which is why like you can go to dinner
with people and you can become friends
with people
and i talked to a big comedian once it
was like jeff bezos invited me to like
his summer camp once and the big
community was like yeah i didn't want to
go
because you start to realize as a comic
you're not supposed to be that tight
with any of these people
because you're gonna have to make fun of
them or something they do
and they're just gonna get angry with
you because they want to own you
they just want to own you you know what
i i
you know so and they're not they're not
like
evil malevolent people they just like
anybody
want to control you they see you they're
like you're a jester
i wanna i wanna own you and i
i want you to poke fun at the things i'd
like you to poke fun at
but i don't want you to say things i'm
not comfortable with
and that's why it's just funny and i'm
like
really insignificant compared to the
person who told me the story about pesos
but
when you even the people that i'm kind
of friendly with now or
in a i know who they are they know who i
am
we maybe go to dinner and maybe i see
them out and they uh you know
or they they have some appreciation for
what i do
they like you until
you cross a line and there's always a
line there's always something
that you shouldn't say or can't say and
as a comic
you got to make a decision you go am i
going to be one of the late night guys
that goes on stage and reads
propaganda that's handed to them five
minutes earlier and then they got it to
like go like
yeah the wall street bats uh people are
russians
but um like you know like poor jimmy
kimmel's gotta run out there and go
yeah the russian disruptors
uh in wall street bets because it's
again he didn't have that thought
does anyone think jimmy kimmel had that
thought i think jimmy kimmel came up
with that
on his way to work he left his mansion
on the way to work he goes
you know who i bet's doing this i bet
it's russian disrupt
no it was handed to him god only knows
how they got into the writers room
there's somebody from the cia in the
writers room which isn't hard to do
you know
so diversity higher right out of langley
here's your new writer
nawazi nabobolo
nawazi where do you come from uh uh
false church virginia shut up don't
worry about it
uh here's the monologue today uh go out
and say they're russian disruptors
uh okay you know
uh here's your new head writer gina
haspel
if you get if you're smarter you get
that but like
that you get that's what you got to do
you got to stay wait that's why now it's
my first episode of taxes i'm in the
hill country
and nobody's told me nobody's like uh
nobody's a fan of rips at
and it doesn't mean that i don't value
what like i have said on my show i think
eric weinstein is an
ally and somebody who i agree with
and i think the version of the world he
would like
is much sim more similar to my own
than the version of the world that his
enemies
would want but that doesn't mean i can't
make a joke here i mean this is absurd
and it's just a little crazy you know
it's a little it's a little crazy
i don't want to be the guy that gets
handed uh notes
to to say uh in between you know ads for
home depot
it's not what i want to do so i i just
got to be a little careful i think you
got to be looking for
i think when people start knowing who
you are and you start becoming friends
with people
and whatever there's weird pressures to
like come down on this side of this or
that side of that
and whatever people want us to have
lunch with all these people now and we
go no
you men go i don't want to have lunch
with you i want to have lunch with these
people
like writers you know writers
journalists want to have lunch with us
for what
why i don't know there's something about
that
where i go oh you want something
you want something and i don't i don't
i'm i'm not interested
in uh sitting down with you and hearing
your
spiel i know the spiel
you know i we see it all the time
these people aren't exactly shy
need to have lunch with them you know
i would like to have lunch with jordan
peterson
because he's a guy that's very
interesting
um to me and i think he's been through a
lot of interesting stuff i think i'm
doing michaela's podcast yes yes
can we have a little fun with the
intellectual dark web
that's all i'm saying can't we poke fun
at the can't you get a little
fun made of you guys and gals
we don't have to get uh our
gender gender-conforming panties in a
twist
we can just enjoy they go that guy yeah
that guy that fat idiot just says what
he wants he's an idiot
that's the response you know but
you know that's right that's where i
live on all this stuff
you can't get too deep into any of these
worlds
because your job is to really try to
make fun of everybody so you know you
can't get it's not a crusade
it's not it's not my problem hey
it's not my problem that your daughter's
soccer going to be taken by a trans guy
i don't know
i may not agree with it but what do you
want how many hours a day do i devote to
that
how many hours a day am i supposed to
devote to that before i just go yeah i
don't
know what to tell you i've i've been
clear about the way i feel about it
if somebody's four and wants to wear a
dress let them wear it i wouldn't start
shooting them up with hormones that
would be my take
but again what am i supposed to do what
am i
i don't understand you're the vaccine
don't love that
but it you know maybe it's better than
covet hopefully i don't know
you'll probably need it to travel i'll
probably need to do my job i'm not
excited about it
what do you want me to do
you want me to go to go
to vaccination sites or right before
somebody gets a needle
just go what's going on here really
god i don't really know about this
it might be good it might not be your
wife just got the second though
[ __ ] her all up but she got back in
two days which means it'll take me two
weeks
they won't even give me this they'll
shoot me up with something i'll [ __ ]
i'll spontaneously combust you know
i'll look at who's giving me the vaccine
i go why is barry weiss giving me the
vaccine
dead right on i'll be dead on the floor
you know i'd love to have her and i'd
ask you a question i go
you love free speech but imagine
i imagine this now i know i'm an
irishman
imagine do you want to play imagine with
me imagine
i am a palestinian professor at columbia
now let's play a game
let's play dress-up i'm a palestinian
professor at columbia
how do we feel about free speech now do
we like it
still we're gonna have anna from red
scaron
she said her mom and her sister really
liked the show and i'm i'm i'm
that makes me really happy but it really
makes me happy
if they watch it while like sitting in
brighton beach just smoking
packs of cigarettes and they probably
don't but just don't ruin it
i just hope that they watch the show
just smoking packs of cigarettes
sitting in a small apartment in brighton
beach with like the window cracked open
a little bit
there's like a picture of stalin on the
wall they're just playing the soviet
anthem they got some borscht
on the [ __ ] stove do people make
porsche in their home i guess they
i think they do yet i'm hoping and
they're just they're just smoking and
there's just clouds of smoke there's
like a russian blue cat or something
you know i don't know
she'll probably i'll probably hear from
her after this she'll go yeah you know
they don't really like the smoking humor
all right well you know what everybody
can go scratch
everybody's sensitive that was the big
baby
the woman who towed the car to texas i
said
i got the car because the car was dirt
she wrote dirty
on the intake form for the car right
cause it's dusty right so i wrote hey i
got it dusty i got it dirty i wanted to
fit in in texas she's like well that's
not nice
like how about you laugh a little bit
enjoy
what's left of your life stop defending
everything
[ __ ] christ already with these people
you know where it ends if you can't
laugh you know where it ends
you end up shooting a woman point blank
range in the face
in the middle of the street in philly
that was probably a guy too
who has seen the show yeah probably
whether he was a fan or not
he is censored yeah ex-military yeah
oh he's seen the show yeah now you know
about it
were they having a uh was this uh a war
that had been going on for a while
supposedly it was building to this
moment yeah an ongoing thing
and he had asked them to stop shoveling
the snow onto his lawn to his credit
he he tried to be nice about the whole
thing you know so i don't know
i don't know man i don't know either
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis do you
want stronger and longer lasting
erections of course you do
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office
no awkward conversations and they're
waiting in line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to your door
in a discrete package the process is
simple sign up bluetooth.com consult one
of the licensed medical providers and
once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done
online their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
don't like swallowing pills no problem
here their tablets are chewable
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct
so it's cheaper than a pharmacy so
chewable tablets
hard dicks so great i know people that
use it it's a lot of fun so if you
benefit from i should use i got to get
free blue chew
so if you could benefit i asked for blue
chew
and they sent me a blueberry muffin so
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform visit
blueshoot.com
for more details bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
bluetooth.com use promo code td to
receive your first month free that's
bluetooth.com
b-o-u-e-c-h-e-w-dot-com
promo code td you get a first your first
month free
and we thank blue chew for sponsoring
the podcast
magic spoon cereal the keto cereal that
we always talk about on the show that's
incredibly low in sugar it's great for
keto diet
it really uses high quality sweeteners
they've released a brand new variety
pack now featuring peanut butter
they released peanut butter as a limited
edition flavor in 2020 and it's sold out
three times
peanut butter has gotten so much love
they've decided to keep it permanent
and add it to the best seller variety
pack i wish ben and jerry's did that
with dublin mudslide but
i've threatened them too many times
the variety pack you get frosted fruity
which i think is the best flavor it
tastes like froot loops and cocoa
and now peanut butter peanut butter
butter
just so tired zero sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and only four net grams of
carbs in each serving
140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly
gluten free grain free soy free
low carb gmo free okay
it's healthy and delicious you can mix
cocoa and peanut butter it tastes
exactly like a peanut butter cup
how great is that how great is that
i'm telling you right now if you go to
magicspoon.com
tim dillon to grab a variety pack and
try today be sure to use our promo code
tim dillon at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
that's magic spoon slash oh
magic spoon dot com slash tim telling to
grab a variety pack and try today
and be sure to use our promo code tim
dillon at checkout to save
five dollars off your order we'll be
back
with a video episode next week with the
studio we're just
we we're trying to get our custom desk
through the door here
it's very tough you know we try to do
the right thing
it's a beautiful home you know we got a
lot of electric stuff
i'll get a cook over an electric stove
like a monster
you need gas you need gas but whatever
i'm not complaining i'm just saying you
know
what are you gonna do this is life now i
can't move every two months this is i'm
settling in
i'm settling in take a breath
and exhale um
uh we're just trying to set the studio
up it's been it's proven a little more
difficult than we had imagined
because these are this is what our
clubhouse another notification from
clubhouse
what's going on now a clubhouse let's
see what's going uh
clubhouse now uh
zuckerberg is doing a room with lindy
england
uh the uh remember the cigarette girl
from abu ghraib
that should be interesting remember the
one who was
sun clubhouse mark zuckerberg
lindy england from abu ghraib are doing
a room on
clubhouse
she's me and ray's favorite go-to joke
reference because most people have no
idea who she is
she's the girl that posed with the
cigarette
[Laughter]
that would be great if that was your
avatar on clubhouse
i'm gonna do a room after this on
clubhouse how to be a cancer influencer
just because you're terminally ill
doesn't mean you can't build a brand
how to be a cancer influencer i did
something else i did uh how to build
your brand while you're incarcerated
prison influencer it's so important
you know those are rooms at clubhouse
and people just just just
just talk and whine all day
because there's also there's smart
people that are whatever doing whatever
the hell they're doing inside of
training probably
and then there's everyone else who's
just whining you know there's not enough
representation in this fake
conversation they're having they're like
uh we don't have enough women of color
here in this
room about uh whatever it is you know
they're like you know like you you'll go
on clubhouse and it'll be like
uh hi we're we're starting a room
to just try to address the lack of uh
uh indigenous music producers
and we're just trying to
we found that there's there's not a lot
of native american
lesbians producing
trap music so we're bringing on
and then all these people are terrified
like because real people get on and
they're like tariffs they have to be
like
she'll bring in like a big dj and he'll
have to be like yeah
yeah i ah that bothers me too
he's all coked out in miami he's like
what is this
people don't even know they get into a
clubhouse room they don't even know
what's going on there's like a thousand
people listening what they say
they think they're talking to their
friends it's some coked out
dj miami's he's talking to his friend
all of a sudden it's like no uh
what's her name my buddy from the new
york times who never mentions me
taylor lawrence she's watching
she just tweeted someone said [ __ ] on
clubhouse because somebody said the r
word on clubhouse
and nobody uh nobody corrected them
jesus and i forget who it was it was one
of these big finance guys
they get on they're thinking it's their
friends they're like can you believe
these retards
and then there's a thousand people there
listening to it
and some of them are journalists they're
just trying to screenshot they're trying
to like screen record or whatever
right jesus
who's she dropping a dime on don't say
the names i don't want to be a rat too
let me see some guy who follows me on
twitter i don't know what he does
she's dropping a dime on him because he
said the r word
i don't know what that means i i imagine
it means a not nice word for the
disabled
let's see
you know what you know what's funny
about these people too they also will
then
snitch on people and then delete it did
she delete it she might have let me see
can you imagine that just hanging out
clubhouse room snitching
like i hope i hope we get the co-founder
of tinder
saying something inappropriate
because i'm a journalist
someone named felicia who who even is
felicia i don't know why what happened
she was the one who said the r word
and then someone named mark also said it
or ben said it she's naming all these
people by the first name i don't even
know
is it a joke should we give her the
benefit of the doubt it's not a joke
maybe
no i don't think it is i don't think
it's a joke she's just
ratting out maybe she didn't understand
the room the clubhouse room that she
went in was called the [ __ ] room
where everyone gets to say the r word
and nobody rats
yeah she has like a time stamp for
youtube she's like at 405 you can hear
ben say alex maybe you could take us
through the
[ __ ] revolution i hope everyone who
uses word can think more carefully about
why people in the audience were upset
how about everybody in the audience gets
off the app and goes and gets a job
because you know why i'll tell you why
you should have kept your mouth
shut god
everyone in the audience is upset you're
listening to someone's conversation
that's a weird thing about clubhouse
it's like
you're listening to a conversation of
people that would never even
acknowledge your existence on earth
that's how they
talk i just wow that echoed
they're gonna throw me out of this area
pretty soon but this is how they [ __ ]
talk these people
don't you want to hear them speak when
you take a safari
you don't want to see the cheetahs
eating dinner with a tablecloth
you want to see them tearing apart other
animals because that's how they live
so why would you want these tech bros to
be like well i
actually believe that no let them speak
how they speak when they're on some
[ __ ] [ __ ] bike ride in silicon
valley they're thrown around
much worse than the r word
the tech bro such an interesting
creature yo bro
bro you gotta roast somebody you gotta
yo let's
trash somebody you gotta roast you gotta
roast somebody you're a comedian
i got an app it's like it's like
instagram but just for pictures of
cliffs
you know what's funny about this too is
she deleted her original tweet
where she accused someone of saying the
r word and then someone who was in the
room corrected her
and then so then she deleted that and
said it was actually this person so she
was slandering somebody
then deleted it and then said it was
actually this person i mean it's just
well she's a journalist ben
she's a great journalist and it's a
great profession of journalists we have
in this country
you should have kept your mouth shut
it's a great profession of journalists
sitting around on clubhouse trying to
catch tech bros being
inappropriate how about reporting on the
hell
world they've created about how about
you do a little research to dark money
where it's coming from
are you worried if that you do that
somebody throw you out of a plane
trying to catch people saying the order
could anything be less important in this
[ __ ] nightmare world right now than
who said the r word on clubhouse
we can't get medicine to sick people
we should just give everyone health care
and before they get it call them a
[ __ ]
you think they would care do you think
they would care
hey you could go to the doctor [ __ ]
you'd be like thank you
thanks a lot
i don't know anymore folks i'm out of
the game
i'm retiring we'll have a video we'll
have video
up next week
we'll try to we're trying we're trying
very hard you know we're we're uh
you know we're trying we're doing
everything we possibly can here
tomorrow's the super bowl do you care
who wins
maybe the bucket here should win huh
make dan kearney happy it's tampa
one for florida yeah why not who cares
tom brady
you know yeah sure he's he's had a rough
life
he's just finally something good happens
to him
i don't know i just hope no one says the
r word
i hope people are in locker rooms
reporting on who's saying the r word
i hope that that that's my only hope i
hope there's an r
word ticker like the nasdaq on clubhouse
where everyone who says its name just
goes
you know what a weird app i could see
that app being like the biggest thing
ever and i could see everybody in a
month going [ __ ]
this [ __ ] sir it's hard to know
hard to know which way that's gonna
which way that's gonna go i'm not
invested in it so i don't have uh
i don't have anything to say about it
but i do enjoy it i do enjoy it it's a
lot of fun
i just don't know uh for how long i'll
enjoy it i mean the rooms are so funny
in there
it's like some of them are really good
but then some of them like i'm on it
right now
and it'll be like you know
it'll be like uh
yeah i mean dude it's weird
people be like let's talk about gen z
i love some of the rooms
conspiracy theories real or fake with
facts
public speaking on clubhouse oh dr
steven greer is live
alien threat hoax exposed yeah
i got into trouble the other day too
because i said is he legit on clubhouse
and people started getting mad at me i'm
there like he briefed
five presidential administrations like
is there any proof of that
they're like what i'm like i'm just
asking a rational question
mr and there might be by the way maybe
he has
i don't know i'm asking a question
and i and then i get attacked for asking
a question if there's proof that he
briefed because so did i then i brief
the last three presidential
administrations on aliens
and by the way who are you briefing are
you from the president are you briefing
somebody that answers the phone at the
white house
because during the trump days like
donald trump jr would like answer the
white house phone
and probably talk to you for an hour and
you could just call up and talk to him
back he went on and he'd go uh that
sounds interesting
i'll tell pop so i you know
can we can we define who we mean when we
say we've briefed the white house
on aliens you mean the president or do
you mean like
someone in his orbit you know
the stars here in texas are very pretty
i'll tell you that
they are very pretty you know
they're sh do you think they and
shooting stars do you ever see shooting
stars out here
oh yeah because they were a lot in the
desert mm-hmm yeah you see them out here
too
do they dye their hair five times on the
way down
anyway
as always folks uh
thank you for listening to just return
for a minute
to that video because it is a haunting
video and i don't want you to go find it
i don't want you to go watch it because
it is disturbing
truly um
but wow what a video
just in terms of content
they tell an entire story in two minutes
and 20 seconds
you know just crazy
it's in plains township by the way i
don't know if that's in philly but
i think that's philly it's in
pennsylvania yeah
another clubhouse room gone wrong
what a haunting image
of that guy very sad
very sad you know but
what can you do you know
this is what happens this is what
happens when people are pushed to their
break don't push
anyone of their break you don't know
who's at their brink you don't know
who's
you don't know who's about to blow you
don't know what their breaking point
is you know
you just don't know folks you have to be
a little careful out there you don't
understand
maybe it's one r word and they're ready
to take out the ar-15
you don't know you don't know
you know they could be one
getting one tweet away
from the end i don't know it was
really it may have been the worst thing
i've ever seen
it's pretty bad yeah it's up there it is
up there
with the worst things
i've ever seen
but
i'd watch it again